JASON KRUEGER: I'm
super excited to be here
with Doug Merlino
for talks at Google.
Doug is an author
who's been featured
in a bunch of
magazines, such as Vice,
Men's Journal, Wired, and Slate.
He's also written
a couple of books.
And today, we're going to talk
about his latest book, which
is called "Beast: Blood,
Struggle and Dreams
at the Heart of
Mixed Martial Arts."
So quick overview.
If you're a fan of the sport,
mixed martial arts, or MMA,
it's been exploding in
popularity over the last 20
to 25 years or so.
If you're a fan, you're probably
familiar with the UFC, which
is the Ultimate
Fighting Championship
and, by far, the most popular
promotional event of the sport.
Essentially, MMA was, kind
of, invented off of this age
old question, which martial
art is the most effective?
For generations, people would
train in Maotai, or kickboxing,
or jiu-jitsu And
pretty much, you'd
spend your entire life
training one martial
art committed to that art
because there was no format
to really test it.
So the UFCs, kind of,
came to be in 1993.
A bunch of Brazilian
jiu-jitsu practitioners
put this event on.
And it brought fighters
of all shapes and sizes
from all over the world.
And they specialized in
different martial arts.
And they put an event on to
really answer that question,
which martial art is the best.
So essentially, the rules are
similar to boxing in the sense
that there is points.
But the actual objective is
to knock out your opponent.
But in jiu-jitsu one of
the things that is popular
is submissions, which is
chokes or joint locks.
So essentially, at the end
of three to five rounds
if no one's won, whomever
has won the most points
by the judges wins.
So that's the basic format.
It's no denying that the UFC
or MMA is a violent sport.
And that's one of
the things we're
going to talk a little
bit about today.
But I think once you get to know
the details that Doug can, kind
of, share, you'll be a
little surprised that there's
a lot of precautions for the
fighters health and making sure
they don't get injured.
While it's, obviously,
a very violent sport
with many injuries, it
probably ranks slightly lower
than boxing, or
hockey, or football.
So Doug, basically, spent
more than two years living
and fully immersed
with the American Top
Team, which is one of
the most popular training
facilities in Florida.
So his book is, essentially,
a first person perspective
of the lives of the fighters,
the business of MMA,
and the history of fighting.
But what I found
most interesting
was the highs and the lows that
these fighters went through.
As you can imagine,
it's a very tough sport.
You only fight a
couple times a year.
So winning and losing is,
pretty much, everything.
So he got to know
these guys really well,
traveled all around the world,
and if you're an avid MMA fan,
it's definitely a cool
book to check out.
But if you're curious to
learn more about the sport
or if you, perhaps, hold an
opinion that violence shouldn't
be promoted in
sports, maybe Doug
can share some
perspective on that
and see if that opinion changes.
So yeah, is that
a quick summary?
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, it's great.
JASON KRUEGER: Nice.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
So thanks, Jason, for doing
this, for hosting this,
and Google.
I guess before I
even get started,
I'm wondering how
many of you guys
either watch mixed martial
arts or do a martial art.
Wow.
Well what do you guys do?
Jiu-jitsu, boxing?
JASON KRUEGER: Shout it out.
It's all good.
AUDIENCE: Jiu-jitsu.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Kenpo.
DOUG MERLINO: Kenpo?
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I'm just a rapid fan.
DOUG MERLINO: Nice.
I mean, one reason I'm asking
is I've done a few book talks
and things at bookstores,
and I've talked
to the Columbia wrestling team.
And there's a wide range
talking to wrestlers.
They're receptive and,
sure, I get what it's about.
In book stores, I've actually
had a very hostile reception
from people who
go to bookstores.
They're like, why?
This is totally sick.
Why would you glorify
this in a book.
And so, usually, when
you go to a bookstore,
you don't get that.
So I think it's a little bit
of a contentious subject.
And hopefully, we can shed
some light on it today.
And it's nice that most of
you guys have a basis in it.
The way I got started and it
was actually just pure curiosity
about four years ago.
My neighbor here in New
York was a big fan of UFC.
And he kept telling me like, oh,
you got to come watch a fight.
You got to come watch a fight.
So I was like, OK, fine.
We go to a bar.
And it's packed in.
It was a big UFC fight.
And you know the feeling
when you're watching a fight.
Everyone's, kind of, pumped up.
It's an exciting thing.
It's two men or two
women really going
at each other in what you'd
call the ultimate contest.
And as we're watching
this not knowing, really,
anything about it,
I thought, like--
well it's kind of crazy
because in my lifetime,
this is a sport that's--
I remember when it started
in 1993.
My friends and I
were like, oh, whoa.
Like, they're going to be
ultimate fighting, cool.
And after, it's grown
into a legitimate sport.
It's broadcast on Fox.
There's billboards
in Times Square.
But I was watching
these guys thinking,
like, you see Brazilians,
you see Japanese, Americans,
Europeans, and thinking where
do these guys come from?
Like, what's the deal?
What's the model of this?
I mean, I know nothing about it.
How did this thing
even start happening?
And when you look around, there
wasn't a lot written about it.
There's not a ton
written, seriously,
about MMA because I think
it's still a bit underground.
Even as it gets more
and more popular,
I found a lot of places don't
really want to touch it.
A lot of editors you talk to
think it's gross or below them.
So basically, I looked
around and found
there's about four or
five really big gyms
in the country that train
dozens and dozens of guys.
One of these is American Top
Team, which is in Florida.
It's subsidized by a guy who
has a timeshare and cruise ship
business.
And it gets guys from
all over the world.
So I went down there.
And the first day I walked
in, I'm watching practice.
Anyone can walk in.
It's a very open sport.
Not like you could go
to the New York Giants
and walk into their
practice and just sit there.
But I walk in.
No one bothers me.
And I'm seeing people
from all over the world
and this whole scene.
Kind of like a gladiator
scene of this training.
And I was thinking
this is amazing.
This is an amazing thing
here that no one's really
written about.
And I talked to
some of the coaches.
And they were very
open and said,
well, if you want to
learn about this sport,
you've come to the right place.
Come into the gym.
Follow us.
Come to our fights.
Do whatever you want.
And so that's how this
project got started.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah.
And what surprised you most?
Like, did you have any
initial perceptions
of what fighters were like?
I think, especially with the
promotions on television,
you know, they're trying
to promote a fight.
So you see only a quick
glimpse into their lives.
But what did you expect?
And when you got in
there, what did you see?
DOUG MERLINO: I mean,
really, to be honest,
I was scared going in.
I was nervous.
And like, I'd been a
journalist for a while
and covered all
types of situations,
and been in some weird places.
So I always know you have
preconceived notions.
But try to set it to the side
when you go in someplace.
But of course you're seeing
the guys who are jacked up,
and they've got
tattoos everywhere,
and cauliflower
ear, and they make
a living imposing their
will on other human beings.
So at some level, I
thought these guys
are going to be really scary.
And in that preconception,
actually, that
was gone after a day or two.
I started talking to fighters.
And you know, these
guys I was talking
to were very humble, very quiet,
and surprisingly thoughtful.
And I think that was one
of the first indications
that, oh, maybe there is
really something here.
Like, this is
pretty interesting.
These guys aren't what one
might think right off the bat.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I actually
practiced Brazilian jiu-jitsu.
Been training about
seven years or so.
A couple of my training
partners are actually here.
And you know, the
one thing we always
talk about is how if you're
not really in the mindset
where you can handle losing,
you usually leave very quickly.
So there's a lot of
guys who come in.
They're big, big weight lifters.
Maybe they've done some boxing.
And the truth is, if
you're not trained,
it's a very technical
sport, Brazilian jiu-jitsu
But it's pretty much
the same whether it's
Maotai, or kickboxing,
or even wrestling.
And any wrestler
from high school
will tell you it
builds character.
And if you can't
handle that, you're
pretty much out right away.
So what's left is, sort
of, like a filtered group
of people that are generally
capable of being humbled.
And was that the
perception you saw?
And were there outliers to that?
Or was that, pretty much,
the dominant presence there?
DOUG MERLINO: I think that
was the dominant presence.
I mean, they had sparring
sessions a couple nights
a week, which could
be really intense.
We're talking 50 men
and a small minority
of women who train there
facing off and sparring.
These are some of the
best in the world.
And different nights
is different energy.
Some nights, it's
fairly low key.
And other nights, there's like
a really aggressive energy
in there that you can really
feel all through your body.
So these are really, really
highly trained individuals,
champions.
But you know, they're facing
off against each other.
And you would see
at this top level
the edge between winning
and losing on any night,
the margin was so
slim that even if you
are one of the best
fighters in the world,
and this is what they
tell me, like, yeah,
I can come into practice
and really get beaten down.
So it's hard.
When you're at that
level, you realize
every little thing counts.
Every mental edge, your physical
being, and how you feel.
And I think, maybe, if
you train in a little gym
and you're really athletic,
and you can beat everyone up,
sure, you might
feel really macho.
But when you get that high,
necessarily, it humbles you.
Now that being said,
there's a couple fighters
who weren't like that who
definitely had temper problems
and other things like that.
And these guys, this minority,
is still pretty high.
But really, the
higher you get, I
can't think of any fight
who has gotten really
to the highest level who still
has that thing because you
hit a point.
You really have to control
your mind and your reactions.
And the higher you get, the
more imperative that becomes.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I
think in competition,
one of the things-- I
compete a little bit
in Brazilian jiu-jitsu.
And it's definitely
not the same.
You don't get punched.
Brazilian jiu-jitsu
is just grappling.
It's basically wrestling,
except it, sort of, embraces
being on your back
where, wrestling,
the goal is to get pinned.
So the goal in jiu-jitsu is
to get joint locks or chokes
and things like that.
But you know, you
quickly realize
that if your vibe is about,
like, high adrenaline, which
you think will give you energy,
it, kind of, blocks the mind.
And I think very
quickly if you just
observe the highest
level of fighters,
you realize that
they're thinking
two, three, four steps ahead.
They're watching their
opponents movements.
They're adapting.
And counter-intuitively, it's
not about getting raged up.
And at that moment, you
don't think very clearly.
And especially for energy
conservation and things
like that, I think
it's very quick.
And you don't even
have to be a fighter.
You just have to be around them.
And be around the top
fighters, for sure.
I think one thing
I noticed-- I've
trained at many martial
arts facilities,
from MMA to just
jiu-jitsu-- and you know,
you can go to the
smaller places.
But you quickly realize when the
instruction level has surpassed
what you can get from it.
And I think it sounds
like American Top Team is
like a breeding ground of people
that have left their smaller
communities and decided
to go to the big place
and say I was the best in
my local town, my region,
but I need to go and
get humbled again.
Can you tell us a
little bit about where
those fighters came from?
And maybe they were the
best where they came from.
And then they came
to ATT, and they just
started from the ground again.
Any specific fighters come
to mind in that sense?
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, I mean,
to give a specific example,
I think we got this
slide of Mirsad Bektic.
JASON KRUEGER: Oh, yeah.
I think we got a
couple up there.
DOUG MERLINO: Let's go to him.
JASON KRUEGER: Who
are you thinking of?
DOUG MERLINO: Mirsad.
JASON KRUEGER: Oh, Mirsad, yeah.
DOUG MERLINO: There he is.
All right, so Mirsad Bektic.
Truly, someone I really
respect and admire.
So he's a good story of who
these guys in the sport are.
So I mean, when I got
to this gym, of course,
one thing I asked the coaches,
I mean, I want to write a book.
And I want to follow a
few guys through the ups
and downs of their careers.
And I have to choose the guys.
And so I asked, who's your
top prospect in this gym?
And it was unanimous that
it's-- he was 22 at the time--
this kid, Mirsad Bektic.
And so he was born in 1991 in
Bosnia when the Bosnian War was
started in Srebrenica, which if
you know that war in, I think,
1995, 8,000 Bosnians,
men and boys,
were rounded up there and
murdered in a couple days.
So he was born there.
But as a baby, as things
were going downhill,
his mom was like, we
gotta get outta here.
So she took him
and his brothers.
His dad stayed to fight.
And they went.
They were in a refugee
camp in Germany,
I think, until he was nine.
And I think it's somewhat
still relevant because I've
been talking to him lately.
As you see, all the
people coming out of Syria
and going to Germany.
This was a generation before.
When he was nine,
she got permission
to emigrate to the US.
They end up going
to Lincoln, Nebraska
where there's, actually, a
fairly big Bosnian community.
They live there.
I mean, I've been
back there with him.
And you know, they're very poor.
His mom is working as an
orderly in a hospital.
This is getting to be post 9/11.
So having a Muslim
background's hard.
You know, he's saying,
at Lincoln High School,
you have all these ethnicities
from all over the world.
And everyone fights.
Everyone fights.
And he's getting bullied.
People make fun of
him for, like he said,
he was this kid
from a refugee camp.
He was a European.
He had long hair
and all this stuff.
And so they're bullied,
bullied, bullied.
He watches his older
brother get beat up.
And he went through
all these phases
of trying to act like
Tupac and whatnot.
But he said when he was about
15, he watched a UFC fight.
He saw this fighter,
George St. Pierre,
who's a really
amazing fighter who's
a very self-possessed,
real martial artist.
Yeah, he's right
here on the screen.
The guy doing the kick.
And so he watches George
St. Pierre and he thinks,
wow, here's a guy
who is a role model.
He's totally in
control of himself.
People look up to him.
No one can bully him.
That's exactly
what I want to be.
I want to be a role model.
I don't want to be
this Tupac loving,
kind of, wannabe be hooligan.
I want to be somebody.
What am I going to do?
I mean, he's a very smart guy.
But college is going
to be a stretch for him
with his financial situation.
And he's not
getting good grades.
So he starts doing martial
arts at a little gym there.
I mean really humble beginnings.
As humble as you can imagine.
And of a sudden in his life,
everything clicks into focus.
It's like this is
his whole thing.
And he trains, and trains,
and trains, and trains.
And his grades come up.
And he showed me a
clip after high school.
The newspaper did a
series of profiles
on kids who were troubled kids
and turned his life around.
And as he graduates
from high school,
he's telling the reporter
MMA turned my life around,
and I'm going to be in the UFC,
and I'm going to be a champion.
It's that age.
And he's like, I'm going to
go train in either California
or Florida.
And so he works his way up.
And this is how
fighters come up.
He moves to Omaha, and
works as a bouncer,
and starts training there,
and starts fighting locally
in these little
things where you get
a couple hundred bucks a fight.
And fights, and fights, and
fights, and fights, and never
loses.
He's getting better and better.
But he's not again
the best training.
And he writes to
American Top Team.
And American Top
Team, it's interesting
because imagine if the
New York Yankees were
like any one of us, really,
can walk into American Top Team
tomorrow and be like,
hey, I'm a fighter.
And they'll be like,
all right, go for it.
I mean, I saw it all the time.
And 95% of the people
last a couple days
because it's a very
tough environment.
However, if you can
last, you can stay.
So he drives down
to Florida and stays
with a friend of the family
and starts training there.
And in one of his first
days, he challenges
one of the top
fighters there to spar.
And so the coach is
like, this kid is insane.
And they start watching him.
And they see all this drive.
And eventually,
after a couple weeks,
they said come join our team.
The owner of the gym, kind
of, subsidizes these guys.
He has a house where he puts
promising young fighters
that they can live for free.
And they're dirt poor
and starts going there.
And he's getting
better training.
And then, even when you're
at American Top Team,
then you're moving up from these
rock bottom level to what they
call the regional promotions.
I went to another
fight in Nebraska
with him while he was still
at the regional level.
And they're televised on
some random cable channel.
And you might get guys from
different states fighting.
And he kept winning and winning.
And during the time I was
following him-- I mean,
he's now in the UFC.
I think he's 3-0 now and
definitely climbing up.
But this is-- is he 25 now?
Yeah, he's about to turn 25.
So I met him four years ago.
And this is how, even
for a top prospect,
this is how slow
the progression.
It's just scrapping
every single level.
And at every level,
you have to win.
Win, win, win, win, win.
And not only you
have to win, it's
best if you're good
looking, or charismatic,
or you can finish people because
it's an entertainment business.
Doesn't matter if you just win.
People want to watch
things that are exciting
or people that turn
them on for some reason.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah,
I think the biggest
detail is one loss can really
put these fighters down.
Not just emotionally,
but on their trajectory
to get to the UFC.
Maybe you just have a bad
day or a hard weight cut.
And you go off to one of
these regional promotions.
You're thinking it's a couple of
fights away from your big shot.
And you know, you've
been struggling.
You're in debt.
And next thing you know,
you'd have a bad afternoon,
bad evening.
You get knocked out.
It looks really bad.
You're physically hurt.
You're injured.
And then, you have
to wait many months.
Six months sometimes,
if you can get a fight.
And like you said, it's possible
that the UFC may never pick you
up if you had that horrible
knockout that other fighters
were promoted upon, right.
So I think it's simple
to say that it's
physically challenging
but emotionally, as well.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, that was
one of the most interesting.
And again, why these guys
are, for the most part,
quite humble because,
for one, we've all seen
there's tons of fighters in the
UFC who have been on the top,
and lost two fights, and
then, they're done with it.
They just go into obscurity.
And especially following these
guys working their way up,
there's so much pressure.
It's very interesting because
it's pressure that we all feel.
Oh, I want to get ahead.
I want to achieve
something in my life.
But it's like, if I had a
job where every four months
I had to fight another writer,
you know, like, one of us
is going to win.
One of us is going to lose.
And the guy who wins
is going to move ahead.
And if I lose, well,
I'm moving back.
And then, you always see
the mental thing of you
have to be very even keeled
because the danger of winning
is you get over confident.
And you don't train as hard.
And you lose the next time.
The danger of losing is that it
can go into a downward spiral.
And when you get that downward
spiral, you lose one fight,
then you lose two fights,
and it's really easy
to slide right down.
So I think following
them for so long, that
was one of the most interesting
aspects is, like, it's so raw.
It's a job like
anything else, but it's
so much more dramatic of this
is the trajectory of your life.
And you're either
making it or you're not.
And it's like, well, I've just
spent all these years training
to be a fighter.
And I'm 28 years old.
And now, if I lose, oh
man, what am I going to do?
So it was very, very,
raw and, kind of,
almost humbling to be
in that environment.
And a lot of stress,
especially following the guys.
You get to be friends with them.
And you realize what's
on the line for them.
And of course, you realize the
other guys on the other side
of the cage are the exact same.
So one person's
going to advance.
And one person's not.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I think
it's very common in many sports
to say this is a game of inches.
Football, you can go
for the fourth down.
You miss by an inch.
You know, hockey, you almost
save the game winning save.
But it deflects off the glove.
But what's most
interesting about fighting
is it's just you.
And the fights are so irregular.
And one slip, one jab,
your timing is pulled off,
your head's not
straight, and that's it.
And like you said, these
fighters are often struggling.
And they have to balance.
Am I'm going to work
a side job or do I
want to commit to training?
And maybe they say, the next
fight, I'll see how it goes.
And it goes well.
And they keep pulling it.
But if they have a family, what
do you do if you have to decide
is this the right career?
Like, you know,
you lose two fights
in a row in some bloody mess.
And for that reason, you
can imagine the stress
these guys are under.
What did you see
when you were there?
I got to imagine when the
UFC or these big promotions
are showcasing these highlight
reels, a lot of times,
you see that tough attitude.
But I have to imagine, when
you hang out long enough,
that shield, that front,
drops a little bit.
Can you talk a little
bit about what you saw?
And if you're
watching, you're bound
to see fighters lose
in sparring or be
frustrated about something.
Did you see a lot of that
when you were hanging out
down there?
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
I mean, that was,
by far, the benefit
of spending so much time there
and getting to know people
because, as a fighter, you don't
want to appear like you're not
confident.
That's going to give your
opponent a great mental boost.
So first of all, when they go
out and are talking in public,
it's all about projecting this
toughness and invincibility.
And also because it's the
entertainment business.
And a lot of people
who watch the sport
want to see that, too.
They don't want to see,
like, Mr. Vulnerable.
I mean, maybe a little
bit of a vulnerability.
But everyone likes their
warriors to be tough.
And when you spend
time with the guys,
that's a lot of
pressure on them.
And I'm thinking
of certain times
after sparring when a guy
had a bad sparring session.
And we went out for
dinner afterwards.
And one guy is like,
man, this is a mess.
I'm broke.
This is a very top fighter.
He's like, I'm broke, and
I'm not fighting well.
And what am I going to do.
The other thing they have
is all these contract
issues with the promotions
they work for that the UFC
or Bellator, the big
promotions aren't going
to tell you in their promotion.
But that's part of
the whole stress
is that it's a really cutthroat
business in every way.
So they're fighting
trying to get money.
And then, the main
thing that really
is hard to see as another
human being with them
is, when the guys lose, that
30 minutes after a loss,
you see someone really
reduce to really a low place.
And you're in the locker room.
And they're just shell-shocked
and don't know what's going on.
And you can only imagine
what's going through their mind
of, like, I've just
wasted eight years.
And then, I could see it of, I'd
say, it was a 30 minute window.
And after 30 minutes,
you saw the ego
start to go up because they
have to go to the press
conference and all that stuff.
And it's back to cliches
of, like, oh, you know,
it was a good fight.
And I'm going to
come back again.
But that was the gift
of being able to follow
them so closely is
that hardly anyone ever
gets to see that because
even if you're writing
about the sport as a journalist,
you're usually in the press
area.
And then, you go to
the press conference.
And that 30 minutes
was like, wow,
that's really what
this is about.
That's really what
this person is
feeling before the [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah,
I think one thing
that the UFC when they
first came out in 1993
was really the
first time, at least
publicly, that these
skills could be tested.
And that's something
I wanted to touch
on a little bit is
fighters could have spent
in the 40s, 50s, 60s, and
70s, studying their Kung Fu
or their Jeet Kune Do with
Bruce Lee and all these things.
But the UFC basically
said let's see what works.
And thinking about a
fighter losing a fight,
I have to imagine one
of the things that
goes through their
mind is should
I have trained more jiu-jitsu.
Should I have worked
on my movement better?
You know, my
flexibility is weak,
but I wanted to train
something different.
And the fact that
this can be tested
is what I think is most
exciting about this sport
and why it's evolved.
And the truth is fighting has
evolved more in 20 to 25 years
then the previous 2000
because there was really
no format, aside from
the gladiators in Rome,
to test this stuff out.
And for example, I
don't know if you
want to share the
history of the UFC
and the Mixed Martial
Arts a little bit.
But what ended up
happening was in 1993,
Royce Gracie came from Brazil.
The Gracie family,
essentially, put him up.
He was the smallest
of the family
because they wanted
to show that it
was about technique and
leverage and not about size.
And he just wiped the floor
with everybody two, three,
four fights in a row.
And it shocked everybody
to say, oh my God,
have I been training the
wrong way for so long?
So that kind of
attitude happens a lot.
And that format of
sparring, whether it's
jiu-jitsu in the gym, or
boxing, or kick boxing, the fact
that it can be
tested, I think, is
what makes this the most
exciting sport right now
because, for so long,
it wasn't that way.
Do you want to give the time
line of UFC a little bit,
and what's changed, and where
do you think it's going?
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
I mean, the first UFC
really was a few things.
One, a scheme by
the Gracie family,
who were the jiu-jitsu
brand, to promote their sport
and to get this massive
everyone against everyone fight.
And show that jiu-jitsu is
an effective martial art
because if you watch jiu-jitsu,
unlike, say, karate, which
has lots of punching
and kicking,
jiu-jitsu is people rolling
around on the ground.
So really, even though they were
trying to promote the sport,
it was hard in the US because
I think a lot of Americans
saw people rolling around
on the ground and thought,
oh, that is not
like Steven Seagal.
That's boring.
So in one sense, it was
just to promote jiu-jitsu.
In another sense, it was
to have a massive spectacle
that they promoted the
violence and the craziness.
So if we go back to the
other slide-- other way--
the first fight with the sumo
wrestler versus the karate guy,
that was the very
first UFC fight.
And the sumo wrestler
charges that they
cried agave cried a
guy moved to the side
and kicks the guy in the
teeth and knocked out
three of his teeth and
that's the end of the fight.
So it lasted 26 seconds.
And then, you had Royce
Gracie, the jujitsu guy,
against a boxer who's
wearing a glove on one hand
and the bare fist in other.
So they have no idea what
they're doing, you know.
And it's a spectacle.
A lot of people
tune in to watch.
Royce Gracie, the
jiu-jitsu guy, won.
But I think it was
like, OK, cool.
We'll get more people in
our jiu-jitsu schools.
And hey, we can make
some money at this.
And I know for a
fact that no one
planned that people would start
taking this seriously and being
like, oh, how can we really meld
all these disciplines together
because people started
learning jiu-jitsu.
So if you just needed jiu-jitsu,
you couldn't win anymore.
And then, they put in wrestling.
And then, they started working
in different techniques.
And as you see over
time, it's actually
involved into a real
fighting technique of its own
that, really, they
did not-- I know
because I talked to the
founders of the UFC--
they did not expect that.
I mean, how could you
predict it until we've got
people who are superstars now.
And you have kids
who are starting
at five years old training
and all this stuff, which
is going to take it
to a whole new level
because now it's
a whole on thing.
You don't just have people who
are an expert in jiu-jitsu who
learn a little bit of punching,
and then try to go in.
Yeah, as far as where
it's going, I mean,
it's hard to say.
You know?
It's hard to say.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I
figured one of the topic,
like, a lot of friends of
mine don't watch the UFC
but everybody
knows Ronda Rousey.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
JASON KRUEGER: She's,
like, the most popular.
I think even Donald Trump
and a few other celebrities
have tweeted about her and
her recent loss to Holly Holm.
But you know, that just
shows how far it's come.
You know, it's come from the
sumo wrestler, the boxer,
and the karate guy to a
fairly different image.
And it's changed
the role models.
It's changed the training.
It's changed the
public perception.
And when it comes to violence,
females fighting in a cage
is, traditionally, not what
you think about as fighting.
But she is inspiring
a generation
of young girls or
boys, for that matter,
to say I can protect myself.
And it's not about spending 30
years or being the biggest guy.
You just got to train correctly,
and train the right things.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, a couple
years ago, the UFC has,
every year in Las Vegas,
they have a big fan expo
at one of the casinos.
So I went to that.
And you got thousands of people
who come and meet the fighters,
and hear everyone talk, and
get autographs and whatnot.
But Ronda was speaking there.
And she was on her rise but
hadn't exploded like she
has in the last two years.
And it was amazing because
she gave a little talk.
And she wasn't
nearly as polished
as she is now, which I
think was part of the charm.
She really came across
as a normal person
that you could relate to.
And then, they have lines
for questions, two lines.
And it was all women and girls
telling her you're my hero
and you're an inspiration
again and again and again.
It wasn't even really questions.
And I think that shows how
this does tap into a deep need
that a lot of people feel
for strength, and confidence,
and the feeling that they're
secure in their own bodies.
And the fact that a woman is
the biggest star, I think,
shows our society is shifting.
And certainly,
women are starting
to feel more empowered.
At the same time,
I think you can't
say it's all one way or another
because the other side of Ronda
Rousey is that she is
very attractive, too.
Would she be as big of a star
if she didn't look like she did?
I don't know.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I
mean, ultimately, things
are changing very quickly.
And what I think is exciting
is it changes what a role
model can be in the public eye.
I don't think
anyone 30 years ago
would have thought that a
professional fighter could have
been one of the most
influential women in the world,
in that sense.
And she won the ESPY
awards last year
for the best female athlete.
So she's getting a
lot of attention.
And to your point, it's not
just about her appearance.
You know, if you don't
train martial arts
or you've never
done Judo before,
I think it's something that you
have to feel it to believe it.
This 135 pound woman
will literally grab you.
And you can be a 240
pound bouncer that's
been wrestling for years.
But she's on a level
that she will toss you.
And until you feel
that power, I don't
think you can really
fully appreciate it.
But that's what I think
the UFC is representing
is that massive transformation.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, and I think
with the other picture up there
is the other biggest star
in the sport today, which
is Conor McGregor, who's Irish.
He's fighting Aldo, right?
Is that fighting Aldo?
JASON KRUEGER: Yep,
it looks like it.
AUDIENCE: It's Diego Brandao.
DOUG MERLINO: Oh,
that's Brandao, OK.
Yeah because the Aldo fight
didn't last long enough
to throw a kick.
But anyways, so another
interesting aspect
of the future of this
sport is that you've
got a Irishman
fighting a Brazilian.
I mean, it's really the
international aspect.
It's expanding across the world.
And it definitely is
something that everyone
can understand fighting.
I know Ireland is
crazy about McGregor.
And everywhere that there is
a fighting tradition-- Japan
or Russia, Ireland,
Brazil, US, and Canada,
too, they're crazy about
it-- the sport is really
catching on.
So it's really going more
in a global direction.
And where that leads in the next
five or 10 years, who knows.
JASON KRUEGER:
Yeah, it's so young
and it's trending so fast.
I mean, I have friends now
that are text messaging me
during events, like, did
you watch this fight?
And these are friends that
don't watch really any sports.
Or some other
friends that they've
been avid basketball
and football
fans their whole lives, and
they do tune in on Saturday
night instead of watching
college football for the UFC
now.
So you can see it changing.
But I think to your point
earlier, the five, and seven,
and 10-year-old
that's starting today
will influence the
next generation.
And really, who knows.
I mean, it's a long way away
from being as mainstream
as the NFL or the NBA.
But it's possible it
can get to that level.
I mean, UFC is now available
for PayPerView on YouTube.
Fox is showing it.
So it's no longer this
small, niche, kind of,
athletic competition.
It's very much in
the mainstream.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah, and
I guess the last thing
I would say on it is that
was why I was playing
with this whole concept
of being a beast
because that's, obviously, a
very common term in the sport
of, like, this guy's a beast
or she's a beast and wider
than the sport calling,
oh, you're a beast,
you got that report done.
Oh man, you stayed up
all night to do that.
What a beast you are.
And I actually use Google.
That thing where you can
search how many terms
are used in books and
I was looking at terms.
And you see in the 90s, in the
early 1800s beast was way high,
which I guess must have had to
do more with biblical meaning.
And then, it went way down.
And then, in the 90s,
it started going way up.
And I think it's more of this
thing of things like MMA,
and CrossFit, and Tough
Mudder are really more
congruent with
the times of like,
OK, things are a bit unstable.
I don't know.
How long will I have this job?
I got to develop myself.
And I think it's why,
30 years ago, people
went bowling because it was like
you're with your colleagues,
and you're having fun.
And now what do people
do in their free time?
They like to go to the MMA gym.
And that's their community.
You're also learning
these skills
and becoming tough and fit.
So it's like you're
not wasting time.
And I think that's part of the
reason why it's caught on now,
too, is that it's individual.
And it shows discipline
and toughness.
And that appeals to people.
And they identify it
with these men and women.
JASON KRUEGER: And we
were talking earlier
about the education
level of the fan base.
And you know, of course,
whoever tuned in 1993
was either a pro wrestling
fan or maybe they were
a martial artists themselves.
But through the 90s and the
2000s, and probably even mostly
today, the average fan
still wants to see blood.
They want to see knockouts.
And I still think, personally,
as a jiu-jitsu player,
I appreciate the small
technical details.
When it looks like two people
are just, like, hugging
and doing nothing
on the ground, I'm
looking to see the
angles they're going for,
and how they're countering
those angles and recountering.
But the truth is
the UFC is still
is trying to attract
those big Irish fan
bases that want to see Conor
McGregor knock someone out.
And over time, I think it will
evolve to have some variance.
But there still is the core
of it, you know, blood lust.
I don't know how you
would stack rank, like,
the best and the worst of MMA.
We talked a little earlier.
What would be, in your
opinion, the best elements
of what Mixed Martial
Arts bring in?
And what would be something
that's, probably, the worst?
DOUG MERLINO: I
think the best is,
for me, is that you see really
the extremes of what humans
can do, in some ways,
in these fights.
There are some fights where
the fighters are really,
really tested to
beyond any level
that you would think
a person could endure.
And they still come back.
And I've seen it on TV.
And I've seen it with
guys that I followed.
And you know what they've gone
through and the amount of pain
and mental toughness that
it would take to keep
going in that situation.
For me, personally,
it's inspiring.
And it's partly
inspiring because it
is on a very brutal level.
I mean, you're getting beat
up, and still keep going.
So you know, it's really a test
of human endurance and skill.
And then, I've been
to certain fights
where there is a high
level of blood lost.
And like we were
saying earlier, I
don't know if
that's good or bad.
I think it's part of this
whole sport because, you know,
it's really combat that's
ritualized inside a cage.
And you have rules,
and you have a referee.
But I mean, really,
it's human combat.
And it's something that we have
done for thousands of years.
But I think it should
bring about mixed emotions
because you do see these
great sides of people.
And you see a lot of
blood lust and desire
to see someone get
knocked out or whatever.
And I think that's actually part
and parcel of the sport there.
Like, it's part of human nature.
I think the same with
football or hockey, too.
Like, you can say
I watch football
for the skill of Peyton
Manning or Tom Brady.
But a lot people like
to see big hits, too.
And if I look inside
myself, I like to see skill.
And then, there is a
part of being a human
that it's amazing
to see violence
that's very skillfully
and forcefully applied.
I mean, not that that's
necessarily good or bad.
It just, kind of, is.
But I found myself,
a times, at fights
feeling a bit uncomfortable
because it was like,
whoa, this crowd is really
revved up for blood.
This doesn't feel good.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I feel like
I started at a small MMA gym.
They trained a little
bit of everything.
And I did the Filipino
[INAUDIBLE] stick
fighting or the kickboxing and
started getting really into it.
And then, they finally
put you into sparring.
And you got the pads
and the head gear on.
But even then, it was like
the first couple times,
you just get hit in the nose.
And your eyes tear up.
And you're like this is not
as fun as I thought it looked.
And that's kind
of where I quickly
gravitated to jiu-jitsu because
it's like you can actually
test it without getting hurt.
And for that, I think that's
one of the reasons why jiu-jitsu
was the catalyst for all this.
It's a sport that you can
train at a very high level,
consistently, on a daily
basis where you can find out
what works and doesn't work
without hurting your training
partner.
And one of the things,
the fan base kind of just
gravitates to
their own interest.
Some fans join a boxing
gym after watching the UFC
for awhile.
But at my academy
where we train,
people come in all the time.
And they say, is this
UFC, or what is this?
And they're wrestlers,
for example.
And over time, if you
start to gravitate
towards a specific art, you
just kind of go to those gyms.
And I think that's
the best part of this
is getting young kids to
train jiu-jitsu, or learn
self-defense, and be inspired
by those role models, for sure.
I think that's the best.
And I agree with you.
The worst is,
unfortunately, I fully
admit I do want to see
Conor McGregor knock out
his next opponent.
Like, I'm super excited
to see him do it.
So I do have to sit
down and say, well, I
agree that it's a
technical sport.
There's definitely blood.
And it's violence at its core.
It's the most pure form of
sport and the most for pure form
of fighting, really.
I think there's a
bunch of Dory questions
that I wanted to quickly get to.
Just make sure we have time.
And we can take some live
questions if anybody has them.
But first, let's see.
It's hard to read up there.
I think the question
is, what would
be the most effective martial
art for women's self-defense?
I'm super biased, but I
think jiu-jitsu just because
of its-- well for one, in
many self-defense scenarios
that women would probably come
across, being on your back,
and learning how
to fight, and being
comfortable in those
scenarios is certainly great.
But just the fact
that you can actually
practice it without
getting injured, I think,
is super important.
If you have a day job
where you can't really
afford to get scratched or
punched and have a black eye,
it can happen.
There's accidents in all sports.
But I'd say jiu-jitsu.
I don't know if you
share the opinion.
DOUG MERLINO: I
would say the most,
like any self-defense
expert would say,
the most effective
self-defense is
running away or de-escalation.
That would be the first
thing in any situation.
And I don't know.
I mean, I think you can
go to self-defense classes
where if you are unfortunate
enough to be in a situation
where you have no choice but to
defend yourself that they will
teach you the most effective
techniques, which are what
you would not do
in a martial art.
A groin shot or
gouging someone's
eyes, the most violent things,
if it comes to that point.
I mean, I would say
either run away.
Or if you are in
such a situation,
then you have to throw
off all the rules.
And I don't know.
Generally, I just think I'm a
big fan of doing martial arts
for one's own
personal development
but whatever you're called to.
If you like jiu-jitsu, cool.
If you like boxing, cool.
If you like Kenpo, cool.
Whatever.
But I'm not sure.
I don't know.
In a self-defense situation,
I would, generally, run away.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah,
and I also think you
can go to great jiu-jitsu
academies and academies that
are just sport oriented.
And I've trained at all of them.
And there's
definitely cases where
I would say I
would not recommend
one school for those reasons.
But I can definitely give a
plug for the Gracie University
or Rener and Rorion
Gracie who are
direct lineage to Helio Gracie.
And they have this
women empowered series
where they, basically, do
those de-escalation techniques.
And they also have a
kids bully proof program.
It's really cool.
And it's all online.
But they also have affiliate
schools all over the country.
But I think what they're doing
is a subset of jiu-jitsu that
really addresses the core
tenants of self-defense that's
separate from the sport.
So I definitely recommend that.
DOUG MERLINO: There's
one other thing
about self-defense
and martial arts
that might sound a little
weird, but I really believe in,
is that not just when
one is getting physically
attacked but, more
often, we're going
to be verbally or mentally
attacked or some other type
of aggression.
That's going to be
much more common,
I think, for everyone here.
And I think doing any
martial arts helps
you get more confidence
and belief in yourself
so that, if you are
in that situation,
you're much more calm.
And you can respond
in a way that
doesn't escalate
and doesn't get in--
or you don't have to freak out.
So I think, oddly, that's
another type of self-defense
that you can learn from whatever
martial art you want to do.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, I mean
even something like yoga
where learning how to
breathe in awkward positions
with good posture.
You know, you look at videos
of kids getting bullied,
it's usually the kid
that's hunched over
and like, kind of, you
know, don't, stop, stop.
But the kid stands up
and he's been familiar
with the basic Judo throws and
done it hundreds or thousands
of times, it just
builds that confidence
because you know I'm
going to stand tall.
And I'm not going to take it.
So I think whatever you
can practice most often.
After hanging out with
fighters for two years,
what surprised you the most
of the life of a fighter?
I think we touched
on that quite a bit.
Are there any unrelated skills,
such as yoga or gymnastics,
that you'd recommend to
Brazilian jiu-jitsu enthusiasts
to explore?
DOUG MERLINO: I
think yoga's great.
That's just a personal opinion.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah,
I think just what
yoga or Pilates offer.
I actually practice both as
a complement to jiu-jitsu.
It's just movement
and flexibility
are great for injury prevention.
I've been injured a bunch.
And I've even stopped
training for many months
at a time and only trained
Pilates after a bad injury.
And I came back, and
I was actually better.
Like, my hips were
more flexible.
And it felt like I can be more
comfortable to avoid bad spots.
So I would definitely
recommend both of those.
I think gymnastics
is wide ranging.
But I don't know if I have
enough experience to say.
Can you scroll down
a little bit to see
what the next question is?
I think you touched
on this a bit.
But what generally happens
to the fighters who
don't make it to the big time?
DOUG MERLINO: They get a job.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it depends.
A lot of the fighters come
from college wrestling.
So they might have a degree.
It's hard one, you know.
One guy I got very close
to was a college wrestler.
And he'd been fighting.
His career was ending.
And this is just like
a personal anecdote,
but he was freaked out.
He was in his 30s.
And he was like, everyone else
is getting married, and having
kids, and has a house.
And I'm broke.
I've been following my dream.
And what am I going to do now?
And we're friends.
So I catch up with
him from time to time.
And now he's been working
as a personal trainer.
And now he's trying to
get his own gym going.
A lot of these guys
are physical people.
So they'll probably end up doing
something along those lines.
But it's not easy because
where other people are building
their careers over their
20s and early 30s, by 35,
your career is done.
So it's really hard
for all of them.
I mean, I don't know any fighter
who really transitions that
well.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, and
it's not just the fighters
that don't make it.
But there's plenty of
examples of fighters
that just make a conscious
decision to get out early.
George St. Pierre, who
you talked about earlier,
he was on a number
of radio interviews
and talking about how he's
having horrible headaches.
And he's known for not
taking tons of damage.
And even he is saying
he might be done.
I think he's talk
about coming back.
But I think it's worth noting
that it's not just the fighters
that don't make it.
It's the fighters that
make a decision that
is it worth the five years of
damage to maybe make it or not.
So some just make the
decision to get out.
And in those cases, they
could be trainers themselves
or go somewhere else.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah,
and unfortunately,
a very common thing
is guys who've
actually made it and done really
well still leave with no money.
JASON KRUEGER: The last
question here is about MMA
and it's illegality in New York.
I don't know if you have any
background to that story.
But for those that
don't have the context,
it's illegal to have MMA events.
So you can't have the UFC
at Madison Square Garden.
They've been trying
to get it for yours.
It's the only state,
actually, that prohibits it.
And it's been constantly
turned down for, really,
some strange reasons.
I don't have the full story.
I don't know if you have
any research into that.
DOUG MERLINO: I've lived
in New York for 12 years.
And I still don't understand
the politics here.
So it seems like some
Byzantine New York State thing
involving unions and whatnot.
I mean, I know yesterday the
senate passed the bill again
for the fourth time.
It's always the assembly.
JASON KRUEGER: And it keeps
getting overturned, right,
after the fact?
AUDIENCE: The recently arrested
the speaker of the assembly,
whatever, the--
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah,
Sheldon Silver.
JASON KRUEGER: There's a mic
there if you want to hop up.
Feel welcome.
AUDIENCE: Can you all hear me?
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: My understanding
is that the speaker who
got arrested has ties
to the culinary union
and general democratic
money stuff,
which because of the Vegas
Casino station casinos, which
are owned by the
same people that
owns Zuffa, which owns the UFC.
The union gets the speaker
to block the pass legislation
from going to the
assembly repeatedly.
JASON KRUEGER: So you
mean there's corruption?
That's crazy.
I think we're
almost out of time.
But does anyone else
have any live questions
they want to ask Doug?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
just one question.
So I'm just curious
about your experience
when you were witnessing
these people train.
Are there any new
entrants or maybe people
leaving from more purist
places, which, honestly, I
thought all the martial
arts were advocating only
doing one thing would
have shut down by now.
But they're still going.
But are there new people
arriving and bringing
new elements?
And maybe, are
they experimenting
with something new that we're
not seeing in the fights yet?
DOUG MERLINO: You know,
it goes up and down.
And for a number
of years, wrestlers
were really dominating
the sport because they
have that background.
And they can get in close
and use their physicality
to control and hold someone, and
punch them, or throw them down.
And then, apply a jiu-jitsu
move or something.
And it's funny.
A couple years ago, one
of the striking coaches
at the gym-- of
course, he's bias
because he's a striking coach--
but he was like, really,
the next thing is going to
be more striking techniques.
Like, you're seeing these
weird spinning kicks
and other things.
And guys are really
going to raise
the level of their striking.
And I think with someone
like Conor McGregor,
you're starting to see that.
He's great at movement.
You see how he's moving around.
His strikes are coming
from all angles.
So I think what this coach
was saying to me it's true.
Like, there's developments.
And when one side gets
dominant, like wrestling,
and then you have a
bunch of wrestlers,
then there's a new space
for other techniques.
So I think striking
is where there's
a lot of new development.
But it's more tweaking
rather than anything.
I mean, I think
what you're seeing
is now a lot of tweaking.
Another thing is just more fluid
melding between all the styles
that you get from people who've
trained it from a young age.
JASON KRUEGER: The
one thing I'd add
is, for one, there's not
just fighting techniques.
But there's weight cutting
techniques, for example.
You know, there's fighters--
for example, Carlos Condit.
I recently listened
to an interview
he had with Joe Rogan.
And he was talking about
how, early in his career,
he would be like eight
pounds away four days out.
And he'd freak out,
and stop eating.
And then, the day of the fight,
has completely burned himself
of energy reserves.
And now he's working
with just a diet
coach that helps him with
preparations for that weight
cut.
So he's actually eating
reasonably large quantities
of food 24 and 18 hours out and
naturally drops that weight.
Just touches down on
his weigh in moment
and then goes right back up.
And they're monitoring
them with technology
to make sure they're
not dehydrated
in the brain and
things like that.
So I think a lot more,
at least right now,
is being focused on
how to actually prepare
for fights physically,
which complements,
of course, all the techniques.
That's happening a lot.
And just to mention Conor
McGregor, him and even Carlos
are actually training less
or sparring less and doing
complementary exercises.
They work with movement
coaches that deal
with balance and coordination.
The same thing with
the old methods
of train, train,
train, train, train.
It turns out that more
is, sometimes, less.
So I think a there's lot
of recent revelations
in that space, for sure.
I think We have time for, maybe,
one more question if anyone
has one or two.
AUDIENCE: I'm taking
this spot again.
In training, these people at the
top level, what did you witness
were the most common
types of injuries?
I mean training.
I don't mean in the fight.
Obviously, they get destroyed.
DOUG MERLINO: Yeah.
Yeah, the injuries
happened all the time.
Every single guy I
followed, everyone,
was injured during
the time I was there.
And we're not
talking head injury.
We're talking things
that come with wrestling,
and going to the ground,
and getting your head
tweaked around.
So there was neck
injuries a lot.
Shoulders, knee,
and all your joints
because you're with someone
and you take a tumble.
And it's really easy
to throw something off.
So yeah, and a lot
of broken hands.
Most of the injuries don't
happen in the fights.
But the one injury that
happens in the fights a lot
is because they wear the small
gloves that they break a hand.
And then, apparently,
once you break your hand,
it's very easy to
break it again.
JASON KRUEGER: And feet.
I mean, hand and feet.
Like, there's so many
little bones, they just,
often, don't recover.
And a good friend of
mine-- actually, he's
a trainer for the most recent
world champion in jiu-jitsu.
And this guy was just
giving a seminar in Brazil
just before the Brazilian
world championships.
Like, two days
before, he was just
sitting on the mat
talking to somebody.
And somebody just accidentally
rolled over his foot
and fractured it.
And it took him months
to recover from it.
And it's like the things that
are not what you expect usually
cause the most frustration.
You know, it would be
one thing if he was
in a fight or training hard.
But he's just sitting there.
And someone rolls on
his foot, and it cracks.
DOUG MERLINO: And
the other danger
of this sport with
training is that you
have to practice jiu-jitsu,
you have to practice wrestling,
you have to practice
striking, and you
have to do conditioning.
So you're seeing the guys
come in in the morning do
a practice.
Then, maybe they work with a
striking or jiu-jitsu coach
on individual skills.
Then, they come back at night
and have another practice
or a conditioning.
That's five days a week.
And then, on Saturday,
they practice once.
So you got so much time
that you're working out.
And time is short, and you
want to get the best you can.
So you want to train,
train, train, train, train.
But all that training
definitely leads
to over-training injuries.
And it's a really hard
problem to address
because the more time you put
into it, the better you get.
But if you put in
too much, you're
really exposing
yourself to injury.
And so I think that's
part of the reason why
the injuries are so rampant.
JASON KRUEGER: The
one thing I'll add
is I've had scares of my knee.
And I've gone to my strength
and conditioning coach.
And I've asked him,
what about this brace?
I've heard this
brand is really good.
And he's like, man, you
just need to do more squats.
You need to do more dead lifts.
And you need to
strengthen your ligaments.
And I think that's where the
science starts to come in.
In the gym, everybody's
got a secret bro science
about what's the right
way to prevent injuries,
and this is the best knee brace.
I mean, the truth
is it's about injury
prevention through exercise
and, like you said,
balance between over-training.
DOUG MERLINO: And that was the
other thing at this very, very
high level world class gym.
The bro science was rampant.
Really rampant.
Even for me, I was
like, oh guys, come on.
And I think that's another
way that, besides guys
like Conor McGregor
who are hiring the best
coaches in the world, even
at the very high level,
it's still, I know, it's
a lagging behind football,
and basketball, and
other sports like that.
JASON KRUEGER: Yeah.
Well I think we're
just about out of time.
So I just wanted to thank
you for coming to Google
and chatting with us here.
And if anyone's interested
in checking out the book,
I definitely recommend it.
I mean, I've watched a lot
of UFC kind of promotions.
But you never really
get into the weeds
of where these fighters
came from and to the detail
that you provided.
So I found it really
enlightening, in that sense.
So I can highly recommend it.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
Thanks for coming in.